la suma de 4 enteros impares
consecutivos es igual a 136 cuáles son
esos 4 enteros antes de que empecemos a
resolver esto vamos a pensar en lo que
significa enteros impares consecutivos a
qué se refiere 4 enteros impares
consecutivos para entender esto podemos
empezar con 3 digamos que tenemos este 3
y el siguiente entero impar sería 5 el
siguiente es 7 y el número impar que
sigue después de este es 9
estos son enteros impares consecutivos y
vamos a ver otro ejemplo si empezamos
con el 11 el siguiente entero impares 13
el siguiente es 15 y el que sigue es 17
un ejemplo de enteros impares no
consecutivos sería digamos 3 seguido por
el 7 estos no son consecutivos el
siguiente entero en par después del 3 es
el 5 17 estos son ejemplos entre los
impares consecutivos y este es un
ejemplo de enteros impares no
consecutivos
después de ver esto vamos a resolver
esta pregunta y los invito a qué pausa
en el vídeo y traten de resolverla por
ustedes mismos antes de que yo lo haga
como pueden imaginar vamos a usar un
poco de álgebra así que digamos que x es
el entero más pequeño de los cuatro
enteros impares sea x el más pequeño de
los cuatro enteros y vamos a expresar
los otros tres en términos de x así que
podemos usar estos ejemplos que tenemos
aquí si este es x como expresaríamos el
siguiente en términos de x
bueno pues éste sería x + 2 el siguiente
entero impar es igual al anterior más 2
lo que estamos haciendo es saltar el
siguiente número que es un número par si
tenemos un número impar el que sigue es
un número par así que para asaltarlo
debemos sumar 2 y si sumamos otros dos
tenemos x + 4 y si sumamos otros 2 a eso
tendremos x + 6 y vemos eso nuevamente
en este ejemplo si este número este x
éste es x + 2 este otro es x + 4
y este es x 6 en general si x es el más
pequeño de los 4 impares podemos definir
los otros 3 como x + 2 x 4 y x 6 y
podemos sumarlos e igualar los a 136 así
que el primero el más pequeño es x el
siguiente es x + 2 el que sigue es x + 4
y el que sigue después de este es x + 6
y aquí tenemos la suma de los cuatro
enteros impares consecutivos y nos dicen
que la suma de estos cuatro es igual a
136 así que lo igualamos a 136 y lo que
podemos hacer literalmente es despejar x
y tenemos solamente una incógnita vamos
a sumar las x que tenemos aquí
x 2 x 3 x 4x y podemos escribirlo como
4x y luego tenemos 24 que es igual a 66
nos da 12 y entonces tenemos 4x + 12 es
igual a 136 ahora vamos a despejar x y
dejar este término de un lado de la
ecuación y quitar este 12 y para
deshacernos de este 12 tenemos que
restar 12 de este lado de la ecuación y
no podemos hacer esto solo del lado
izquierda de la ecuación porque entonces
esta igualdad ya no se cumpliría estos
términos eran iguales antes de restar 12
y si queremos que sigan siendo iguales
estos dos lados de la ecuación entonces
tenemos que restar 12 del lado derecho
también vamos a restar 12 de los dos
lados de la ecuación así que de este
lado restamos 12 12 menos 12 se anulan y
nos queda solamente 4x y del otro lado
tenemos 136 menos 12
igual a 124 y ahora cuál es el valor de
x pues vamos a dividir los dos lados
entre 4 así que dividimos el lado
izquierdo entre 4 y el lado derecho
entre 4 y obtenemos x del lado izquierdo
y de este lado tenemos 124 entre 4 100
dividido entre 4 es igual a 25 y luego
24 dividido entre 4 es igual a 6 así que
25 6 es igual a 31 de este lado tenemos
31 si les cuesta un poco de trabajo
hacer esta división en la mente pueden
hacerla de la manera tradicional
entonces tenemos 124 entre 4
el 4 no cabe en uno entonces tomamos el
12 y el 4 cabe en el 12 3 veces 3 por 4
es igual a 12 y restamos y ahora bajamos
el siguiente dígito que es 4
y 4 cabe una vez en 44 por uno es 4
restamos y el residuo es cero
x es igual a 31 y x es el más pequeño de
los cuatro enteros esta x de aquí es
igual a 31 x + 2 es igual a 33
x 4 es igual a 35 y x 6 es igual a 37
así que nuestros cuatro enteros impares
consecutivos son 31 33 35 y 37